[Music]
so the question is why are all these
Muslims so riled up that's what we're
going to be discussing here they're more
important and I'm the one that's going
to send a message to everybody we are
not gonna tolerate this the school board
to walk out as a school board
you allowed someone to stand here for
three minutes
and disparage the Muslim faith
you did not stop it several books once
available to students are banned in
Dearborn Public Schools tonight it
follows complaints from parents who
believe the content is dangerous one mom
even filed a police report now these
Muslim parents obviously you can see
they're very very upset so are the
Christian parents and other parents
because they're sending their children
to school
to learn Reading Writing and math but at
the same time now their children are
being exposed to pornographic content to
sexually charged explicit content in it
there are actual and if you read the PDF
which we've done here at Fox 2 it shows
you how to have sex with someone else of
your same sex it actually has like
diagrams and whatnot pornographic and
have absolutely no place in local
schools that they support with both
their children and their tax dollars
there's a etzel Ford sticker on here
Stephanie Butler says her daughter
checked this book out today at Edsel
Ford High School it's titled flamer it
depicts sexually explicit acts between
young boys some with graphic
descriptions you know when you put
something in a kid's mind it makes them
want to do it more or try it a normal
psychologically sound and stable mind
would come to a conclusion that that
specific material is nothing but
sexually explicit education if democracy
matters we are the majority here in
Dearborn let us draw the boundaries on
appropriateness every parent has a right
to object to the things their kids are
being exposed to but there is a Breaking
Point and the breaking point is this the
fundamental existence of school is not
to learn about sexual pleasure to not to
learn about new sex acts the fundamental
purpose of school is to prepare our kids
to be successful adults who can go off
and have careers
and it is up to every parent
to then teach their kids morality it is
out of the place with the school to do
it and I reject any notion that parents
here are filled with hate or bigotry the
parents don't want their kids sexualized
if other people want to sexualize their
kids that's their business it's not
about books it's what's in the books
we're here just to talk about the books
and the pornography the rights of the
children
um I have to say I looked up some of
these books and like you said I mean if
you can't show this on the air then it
should not be in a 10 year old's
classroom now there's a few issues here
I just want to touch upon because if
these books were at the same time
covering on 101 ways that a husband can
have his wife please excuse the language
have an orgasm
this would also be something that the
Muslims Christians I'm sure and other
god-conscious people morally upright
people would object to people who want
to live a decent life a morally upright
life they wouldn't want their children
even exposed to this type of stuff at
such a young age
at the same time if there was explicit
content showing how a husband even
though we know this is something that's
forbidden in Islam but if there was
something of this type of nature where
it was showing a husband
having sodomy with his own wife this
would be something and if they were
showing this to the children a how-to
manual
this would be something that the Muslims
and I'm sure probably Christians also
would be protesting so this is the issue
because this book in particular
it's a how-to guide it's very very
explicit that's the issue at hand it's
one thing you're keeping your Private
Affairs in your bedroom to yourself but
now the same objection even if these
were books were about husband and wife
action or man on woman action
porn of pornography this would be
something that would obviously be
protested we wouldn't want our children
to be exposed to these things so I want
you to imagine if you had an individual
who came to a children's park
and that individual was showing this
book and all the explicit content that
it had in there to children at the
playground what would happen to this
individual he probably could charge and
arrested so what difference is it if it
is by a teacher in a school showing
these explicit things to it to a young
child it's nonsensical it makes no sense
so these things are not being approached
logically scientifically Godly
religiously
things are being emotionally driven and
people who object to this are labeled
with certain labels so board members and
other people I'm sure who also know that
this is very distasteful this is some
this is corruption this is something
that our children you know should not be
exposed to they're also scared to speak
out because their fear the repercussions
of being labeled certain derogatory
names and possibly the repercussions for
that but when you see Christian Muslims
here uniting they're forced to be
reckoned with so other communities
should take example because this is
something that's happening in other
cities so this is a great opportunity
for more Muslim and Christians to really
work together and to show their
cooperation in this area and to stand up
within the law to stand up and speak out
against this the other thing I just
wanted to touch upon is
this is a great opportunity for those
Muslim politicians there's some very
loud voices out there who have been
known to support certain causes and to
step up this is a great opportunity for
them to step up for these parents rights
to be heard to go come out and to speak
up also organizations such as care and
others this is a great opportunity they
do some wonderful work in certain areas
this is a great opportunity here to go
ahead and to step up to help these
parents to be a voice for these parents
it is also a great opportunity for those
Muslim leaders to go ahead and to speak
up to come out and to support to help
not just Muslims in this
City in Dearborn but also other cities
this issue comes up in Dearborn but it's
the same issue we're seeing in Grand
Rapids we're seeing it in Kalamazoo
we're seeing it in northern Michigan
we're seeing it everywhere where School
boards think that they can ignore the
rights of the parents in terms of how
their children are educated and speak
out against what's happening
to our children this attack on our
children we've been told that they're
out to kill us all assalamualaikum
brothers and sisters we went to the
streets to ask Americans about Islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all that's what you've
been told that Muslims are out to kill
you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click the Donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you are not yet Muslim and
you tune in to see what these Muslims
are talking about and you like a free
copy of the Quran go and visit
thedenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum